لواء فايز الدويريا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي السيد اللواء اليوم
ضربت موسكو مره اخرى بطائرات مسيره ما هي
القيمه الفعليه لمثل هذه العمليات التي
تتم بواسطه طائرات مسيره
يعني دعني لا انظر الى القيمه الماديه
المباشره الان تم اصابه احد الطائرات سواء
بحطام الطائره التي تم اسقاطها او ان
الطائره نجحت في الوصول لانه لا يوجد خبر
يقين لكن دعنا ننظر الى الجزء المليء من
الكاس ما هي الانعكاسات في البعد السياسي
في البعد الاقتصادي في البعد الاجتماعي في
البعد الامني واخر شيء نتحدث عن البعد
العسكري لانه في هذا المستوى هو الادنى
تاثيرا
لاحظ رد الرئيس السابق
ماذا كان ملخص كلامه كان يتحدث وكانه يعبر
عن الالم بان هذه الحرب ستطول ويجب ان
نحقق ويجب لماذا لان هناك اختراقات
لنعد الى تصريح قائد قوات الفضاء الجويه
انقطع الصوت ماذا قلت في الاخير
عسكري في مواجهه مثل هذه الهجمات
بالطائرات المسيره هل تتوقع يكون كرات من
روسيا على اوكرانيا
الرد الرد قائم الان قسم تشيرني هيف
انفجارات في كييف قصف في
مناطق متعدده اذا الرد قائم التصعيد موجود
من الجانب الاوكراني وتصعيد مقابل من
الجانب الروسي لكن السؤال الذي يطرح دائما
هل تستطيع روسيا ان تمنع هذه المقاربه
الاجابه قطعا لا ليس فقط لانها روسيا لا
روسيا ولا غيرها من دول العالم المتقدم
تستطيع ان تحقق الامن المطلق لجمله كبيره
من الاسباب علينا ان ظن ننظر الى الخارطه
او منطقه التاثير هنا لا نتحدث عن شرق
اوكرانيا انا اتحدث عن الجغرافيا الغربيه
لروسيا اتحدث عن الاف الكيلومترات اتحدى
كقياس طولي اتحدث عن عشرات الاف الكيلو
جرامات كيلو مترات كمساحه لا يمكن السيطره
عليها شكرا لك فايز الدويرية الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي متحدثا من عمان
السيد لواء شكرا لك